anger and frustration on the streets of
colombo
months of shortages with no end in sight
we need a guest
only guess
yes
yes i am a mother i am a mother mine
style i have i can't give anything to
ask my child
we need the action not the debates we
don't need the words
gas prices have almost tripled since
last year
sri lanka is facing its most serious
economic crisis ever
and the poor are suffering the most
gas food fuel and medicine there isn't
enough of anything
and what's available is becoming more
expensive by the day
charmingly earns two dollars a day
most of that is spent on kerosene for
cooking
my
there are five people to cook for and
her shopping bill has almost doubled in
the last three months
sometimes it all gets too much
but no help is coming
not yet
anyway people are dealing with this
crisis on their own
[Music]
sri lanka is almost broke there's a
tanker of fuel out there waiting to
unload but the government can't afford
to pay for it there's simply not enough
money left to keep the country afloat
with sri lanka on the edge of economic
collapse government supporters attacked
peaceful protesters
beating people
destroying tents
nine people died and more than 200
injured as violence spread across the
country
[Applause]
vishwa was one of them punched by
supporters of the now former prime
minister mahinda rajapaksa
even as he was beaten he held onto his
phone and kept filming
the protesters anger now focused on
president rajapaksa known as gotha
[Applause]
right now there's no solution for sri
lanka's problems
and without one
the likelihood of more violence
grows stronger nicole johnston sky news
colombo